taste buds they come to the mic talking
about the food they hate talking about
the food they like two fools going to
fight but only one food can be right
tast buds
man hey welcome to t a s e buds taste
buddies it's a big day here at the taste
buds
podcast it is the finals and semifinals
of the French fry
battle oh I love the energy you're
coming in with and we got a friend here
of the show well not a friend a new
friend of the show he's never been on
the show but a friend of ours in life
yes Mr Joe bartnik in the house what's
up guys Joe S what's going on I am I am
a fan of the show thank you I listen to
except when there's a topic when I don't
want to know what side you're on I don't
listen like Coke and Pepsi like I don't
want to know who's don't even tell me
now cuz I don't want to disown one of
you oh wow oh that's good no that's we
need that fire here I I literally was
like oh my God they're it would be like
I didn't even know what this kind like
dogs and cats you got to be a dog guy I
can't even respect a cat the way you're
talking I feel like you're Coke coca has
to be
cook took Pepsi in that oh my
God I now I turn my back on you I love s
what's going on it's like the Yankees in
the I I get it I get it but something
about Pepsi man I don't I'm not a big
soda drinker but just in in his
historically uh I don't know I just just
something a little different about Pepsi
that that was one where I was convinced
that you Coke one right yeah I I don't
keep I don't keep numb but I was
convinced that you just wanted you were
like let's just get on with it I'll take
Pepsi no no I I do I do have love for
Pepsi really uh nothing like the Pepsi
can I will say that the classic Pepsi
can is the Mexican Coke bottles the best
Mexican Coke is another level of Eno
dude real sugar the caffeine I say it's
like getting a hug from a chubby Latino
Lady it's just all warmth and love man I
it's the best I love it I I I have and
and you know I have a bottle like a
bigger one the old school big ones like
that big and I I've never I can't throw
it out it's like it look it's like it
feels like it's a it's an antique well
it's America s it's like literally like
no it's not it's Mexico I mean like well
you know that's half of America anyway
it's like it really like if the Mex like
the actors went on strike nobody knew or
care in America the writers didn't know
care if the Mexicans ever go on strike
the world's shutting
down would be the pandemic everyone
would be in their house cuz no there
would be nowhere to go everything would
be
closed that's hilarious they they yeah
yeah uh we're gonna jum Joe we're going
to jump right in uh you are not familiar
with what we've been doing here but
we've been doing a french fry tournament
now today we've Madness we've done two
full we have fun here we've had two full
episodes today we're in the final three
battles meaning the final two battles of
four different fry groups that will then
select the winners that go to the final
battle we're also going to do the final
battle today this is all in your head or
is there's a chart somewhere uh we did
it on oh it's right here I'm sorry no no
no well it's not right there but we did
it on you know we did po we did the
polls and stuff so oh right on
so the last thing in order of t.
Seas you're particularly like uh
like this yeah looks perverted almost uh
pimp what is the first battle today well
can we just recap can we give everybody
for people just tuning in now let's
recap the first battles pimp I don't
want to go on the timeline because I
don't want to see the results right now
for today what we posted um we do want
to get because I the obviously the last
one has to be posted in real time the
finale oh okay right right because we
need to we need to poll right so um I
don't know if that's up there ated I was
going to just say to for you to look on
your phone at the last uh this well
let's see oh wow season 3 okay here we
go but we did more than that we we've
done two episodes
so so all right well we know we did
Curly versus crinkle gut Joe tell me
what you would take in each of these
just so we get a feel of where you stand
as a fry guy abely yeah I love fries by
the way the Fry Guys unsung heroes I
think they're some of the best
characters they were
Pac ghost you're bringing up McDonald's
yeah I know but I I because because
we've we've actually talked about
everybody on this podcast in that
universe but the fried guys no I I
believe we've talked about the fried
guys I can't imagine we haven't what are
the fried guys they're fries s the hell
do you think they are they're fries
they're humanoid french fries yeah
they're like Bush they're
personification french fries supposed to
be all that like hair is like the
strands are supposed to be fries I don't
know about that Joe why are they red and
blue so what else do you think those
things that that represent fries hanging
off I think they're Critters that love
to eat fries like Cookie Monster is not
a cookie all all right I I think that
they're oh you're right God okay okay
again okay I just want to let you know
that in every single episode at least
one time you make me out to feel like
I'm being ridiculous you throw down the
gauntlet and say you what you Mock
roundly and then you double down and
then it comes up and on Jo I'm not
saying I don't do that but it's also
your fault it's a pattern it's my fault
but it's it's
[Laughter]
par we probably we can't show this right
look how creepy these things are
really I mean that looks like an acid
trip right there it certainly does very
H&R puffing
stuff I mean what's going on I don't
even know was like it looked like a key
party with the Fry Guys and Ronald yeah
it's like Sid Sid and Nancy Croft went
to McDonald's yeah who's the guy there's
two guys on stilts one's Ronald the
other one's like a professor of some
kind who's very creepy
looking how is this moving Burgers it's
unbelievable anywh who anyway so there
they are Critters who are just hellbent
on eating fries yes all right yes so we
did Joe the first tournament had curly
fry versus crinkle cut fry where do you
stand there you think H the cold kind of
Frozen in the bag crinkle cruts no think
of the best version well that no
seriously I see what side you're on no
no no I attached my argument and my and
my feelings to that because I I felt
they were low-end potatoes uh low I
don't like hold on don't sway him hold
on let me just say I'm not saying this
to sway you for on crinkle cut I'm
saying we said repeatedly for every fry
freezer aisle fry is always going to be
the worst version of it so think of the
best version you've had of any of these
fries and which you would prefer in in
in the head-to head in the in the the
curly cut has that spicy seasoning that
whatever that going to kill your early
Factor yeah um I I think I like that
more than the crinkle cut I I do but
it's close cuz the crinkle cut is almost
my least favorite of any fry me too okay
I love the crinkle cut crinkle cut lost
to the curly fry crinkle cut really got
its ass handed to it yes it a squash
match 67 68% almost the curly fry won by
so curly fry is in today's semi-finals
but then you came next one yeah
traditional versus sweet potato oh
traditional 1,000% okay I I sweet potato
one the only things I really don't like
and you always have someone go no you
haven't had my grandmother make it it's
it's always terrible I had I had
traditional in that fight and I won by
87% yeah well that's that that's like a
Big John Stud out in is a squash match
it is a show I'm I'm just going to ask a
a fan or a listener guys can you let us
know is that the biggest margin of
victory in taste buds history this
crinkle cut versus sweet potato uh
classic versus sweet potato cuz I think
I don't I don't know if we've ever hit
the 90s have we I think we have but I
can't I don't remember so okay so now
we've got traditional and curly fries
are in the final okay and then we also
did we did steak cut steak Cut's nice
okay versus steak cut tater tots oh well
then that's almost a different category
yeah that's really kind of pushing the
March that's like that's like when the
Catholic League lets in like a city
school it just gets their ass handed to
like no one's taking tater tots over I
mean everyone's taking tater tots over
anything else yeah they that's why it's
a $3 up Tater CHS versus I mean you're
not listening he's got some amazing know
I want to know the results of tater tots
versus steak fry okay yeah do we have
those yeah we did it already didn't we
no no no do we have the
results we did didn't we do four yeah
yeah that's why I'm saying I want to I
want to because we're pulling up the
results he just called out that tatato
tots is going to beat everything and
that he he he also said there's a $3
upcharge for tatato Tots which which
should speak volumes is what he's saying
okay all right that's a great Point well
it's demolished steak fry steak cut fry
yeah tater tots won so tater tots are in
our finals and last but not least we had
waffle fry versus shoestring fry ooh
come on bab now this is a this is this
is like a a 56 seed this is like the
Sunday Mar this is he who goes to the
final four yes oh man but they're
Scrappy you know they you they could
they could do something they could
surprise us oh no I'm sorry waffle fry
went against steak fry okay waffle fry
waffle fry went against steak fry that's
a good one that's a good one too that's
a good one too
um I might go nice steak fry over a
waffle fry there I waffle fries are very
good though not knocking an aw waffle
steak fres is like a regular fry just a
little thicker yeah you'd be wrong and I
attach it to Classic Diner Burger you
know what I mean yeah especially a
crispy waffle fry now that's the problem
with the crinkle cut usually it's a
little too moist in the middle a little
too uncooked and you think the curly
fries is cooked all the way you got a
lot of balls coming in here with that
65% the waffle fry beat out stay FR Mak
fries into the finals and then last one
I was tater tot versus Sho St that's
fair cuz Shing should be like it should
be the finals Shing should it should be
shring versus waffle maybe
well is a whole another but I'm saying
the tater tot should be in the other it
should be in like the mac and cheese
category our for S insisted Tater tou go
into this battle we had a discussion he
made his bed and he slept in it because
now hon I think I think that that was a
real upsate uh up upset first round
elimination for shoestring cuz
shoestring is my favorite fry well Sho
string is technically like the
McDonald's fry right that's the
traditional oh okay sh string are like
you remember those Potato Sticks Sho
string is like half the the width of a
McDonald's the on get super crispy they
just look like a bail of hay sometimes
you never get them anywhere yeah they're
hard to find they're hard to they're
hard to find which makes it even better
which makes it even better here's what's
interesting Joe but I do like the that
waffle steak fry is a tough one man cuz
like a waffle fries killer too yeah
competing french fries so this is really
you really threw me into the tough uh
the Tough by is fun but this is fun and
here's what's interesting about today
not just having you now in on the potato
discussion you're bringing a lot of
flavor and new points which we love okay
but here's what's interesting we have
four semi-final potatoes and three of
them are my wins oh so s is now forced
to defend at least one fry well not
necessarily lete let Joe defend no but
no no but but no no no I'll we're going
to go into the finals but I'm just
saying just for the fun of it he he he
he has no but your lost counts as a
second law you these count we're in a
tournament baby no no no it's okay these
count as L's okay it's all right yeah
but but at least it gives him a chance
at least it gives him a chance to argue
with a fresh perspective on both whereas
I'm just going to be now making an
argument for the one that you don't want
you know what I mean I just think he
brings I'll take I'll take his his l or
his W also when is being punished again
when is that happening I know because
season two you also lost now season
three the writing seems to be on the
wall for
myself season two punishment on the
cruise oh my God that's good Joe yeah
that's good if you're watching you know
did we announce that there'll be two
live taste buds on the in practical
joker Cruise January 22nd to the 26th
2024 leaving out of Miami going to the
Bahamas with Eric Andre steo has been
booked and uh a bunch of bunch open I
will talk to you so my we're doing my
season two punishment should be the
cruise and your season three punishment
if you Lo whoever loses e way should be
next live stream punishment okay fair
enough yeah that's good that's good so
there you go if you are uh contemplating
going on the cruise we were going to
cook up something real nice for you for
your second season punishment on that
cruise we'll figure it out okay so who
what are our matchups today okay so
today we have uh curly fry by the way I
just want to say I think curly fry and
waffle fry are the same thing cut
differently and I like curly fry better
than waffle nuts they are like in the
same family CU they almost always get
the same kind of spice rely had waffle
fries with this spicy seasoning that the
curly fry has only ever had curly fries
with that seasoning and I hate it
I'm I'm 9% seasoning when I get a waffle
fry versus the plain waffle fry so I I
attach miles of WAFF it be interesting
to have them go against each other
because they're very similar so what are
the M what are the matchups then you're
not debating seasoning you're debating
fry uh look at this this guy made
sliders where the waffle fries are the
bun I mean God that's awesome pretty
damn good that's awesome okay but so let
me we can recede right now actually we
can recede what do you mean recede like
we have the
four don't we have we have four we have
two battles for the semi-finals we got
to get through those get to the finals
right but we can we don't know who's
going against who we didn't have AED it
yeah you did poed yeah so what did you
that's what I'm saying what did you do
it was it was um curly fry versus no
waffle fry versus tater tot okay and
curly fry versus traditional yeah I mean
this is where the big boys come to play
yeah this is it you know what I mean
now these are you put two of my wins
together because you had two but well I
mean one of them no matter what you
chose had to be that right yeah
so I mean I fig you're literally playing
I think they both amazing battles
because traditional versus curly is huge
traditional versus just curly I'll take
traditional you'll take curly but tater
tot waffle I mean I would take tater
tots in that yeah well that's why that's
why Joe bnck entered the chat okay so
what does Joe Joe has to do waffle fries
but Joe doesn't feel strongly about
waffle fries I I definitely feel the
tater tots wins this unless except
sometimes you're not feeling a feeling a
tot and you go traditional fries tell
the thing you're you're always in the
mood for a traditional but there are
sometimes when you're not in the mood
for a TOD have been I have seen tots on
a menu and passed I haven't ordered a
tot every time a tot's been in front of
me exact I'll tell you what I'll tell
you what let's just see who won this one
and let's move on to the next semi-final
battle and get to the bottom I get to
because then we also have to do the
finale exactly all right pimp show us
who w Wait wait can we take a little bit
of a wager I mean we all think tatlor
tot is taking let's give give me margin
give me margin okay I think waffle fry
is I think it's a I think Todd is going
to demolish WAFF think a pretty decent
adversary but I'm going to say you're
going to get do you want to go to the
phones a little bit no no no no let's no
cuz we got we got to do two other
battles okay
let's shks I have a feeling we're we
have lower freeze we have our work cut
out for us in these next two battles I
and I I want to in the we're at 16
minutes yeah yeah we're good yeah we
have time all right some phones I mean
it's the fun fun part of it so I mean
why not why not give them their do their
due we are in the next battle saying all
right guys let's talk about factor with
the busy fall season already in swing
you might be looking for wholesome
convenient meals for jam-pack days
Factor America's number one ready to eat
meal kit can help you fuel up fast with
Chef prepared dietician approved ready
to eat meals delivered straight to your
door you'll save time you'll eat well
and stay on track with your healthy
lifestyle uh I use this I am not a cook
I've said this before I order Factor
comes every Wednesday for me um it's two
everything comes fresh now Frozen takes
2 minutes to heat it up in the microw
wave uh and it's they have I just chose
my my plan for the next week I choose
them every week and what I love about
factor is I am somebody who likes to
cook and I still love Factor because I
love it for the convenience and I think
that the meals taste outstanding uh
especially that they're coming fully
prepared I love that they've got 34 plus
weekly flavor packed fresh never frozen
meals ready to eat in 2 minutes they got
Gourmet options they've got uh
vegetarian options they've got uh uh
they've got every option
Protein Plus meals they have cold press
juices they also have um um smoothies I
love it actually also too they're
they've got breakfast items now like
apple cinnamon pancakes and bacon and CH
that I didn't know egg bites and nice
Factor potato bacon and egg breakfast
skillet and all kinds of good stuff head
to factor meals.com tastebuds 5 and use
the code tastebuds 5 to get 50% off
that's code tastebuds 50@ Factor
meals.com
tastebuds 5 to get 50% off folks let's
talk about sleep and let's talk about
what beam dream powder is doing to help
you get some better sleep did you know
that poor sleep can cause weight gain
yes I do do you know it can cause mood
issues yes I do do you know what can
cause poor mental health well yes I do
can also affect your productivity
sleeping less than six to S hours per
night is linked to reduced white blood
cell counts white blood cells help
protect your body against illness and
disease and fight viruses and bacteria
and that sort of stuff and sleep is
crucial for that sleep is the foundation
of your mental and physical health and
your performance during the day so a
consistent nighttime routine is not
negotiable okay uh today our listeners
get a special discount on beams dream
powder they're bestselling healthy hot
cocoa for sleep with no added sugar now
available in delicious flavors like sea
salt caramel cinnamon cocoa and ch
chocolate peanut butter better sleep has
never tasted better a recent clinical
study revealed dream helped 93% of users
wake up feeling more refreshed and 93%
reported that dream helped them get more
restful nights sleep so if you want to
try beam's bestselling dream powder get
up to 40% off for a limited time when
you go to shop
beam.com tastebuds and use code
tastebuds at checkout that's shop
bam.com tastebuds and use code tastebuds
for up to 40% off folks CH toosa here I
got some live dates coming up I'd like
to tell you about why not uh I'm doing a
special show on November 9th at the KGB
bar New York City as part of the New
York Comedy Festival the show's called
selected readings where I'm going to be
reading excerpts from my audio book The
Penthouse papers released on uh a
special thing records and I'm also going
to be reading some other stuff I had
published over the years I'm looking
forward to that then I'm hitting the big
open road getting out of my own town
where I live and I'm coming to you with
what I Never Promised You a Rose Garden
live the new hour very proud of this
show November 11th hit in Philadelphia
PA theater of the Living Arts November
17th Pittsburgh PA at Bottle Rock at
Social Hall November 18th Buffalo New
York theater at senica 1 the 30th of
November Denver Colorado at the summit
December 1st Phoenix Arizona at the
crescent ballroom and December 3rd Salt
Lake City Utah at the soundwell folks
we're adding dates all the time but for
these dates and ones we might add later
you can go to joa.com for Ticket links
and show information and of course if
you are in New York City and you want to
check out my establishment Joey roses
come on down we're open 7 days a week
11:30 a.m. every day we open those doors
for affordable booze and delicious
affordable sandwiches Joey roses nc.com
what's up guys real quick tour dates are
on sale right now at salvano comedy.com
there's a big Illinois run in November
leading up to my comedy special at the
Vick in Chicago on December 1st and 2nd
the second sold out as you guys I
hopefully know uh and so we added two
shows on the first all will be taped and
all if you have a ticket to any of those
shows you'll be eligible to win uh a
flight hotel and trip to the set of
Impractical Jokers I'm choosing one
ticket out of those four shows
uh December 1st is still on sale right
now but it's going fast savalan
comedy.com hope to see you guys on the
road let's go tater tots but only if
they're real crispy most of the time
they're soggy and sad that's well now I
and I walked into this fire storm I
heard we're thinking of the best
possible of each of these that's right
okay that's right as told by well no no
no I mean Joe D Ro yeah but no no but
but but but just but conversely you
could also be like these are the faults
as well oh oh yes exactly yeah tots are
not a fry somebody said I feel like the
only people who eat tater tots are old
people and
babies you never know where the wind's
blowing this week I do love both but the
chunk of potato created at the end of
waffle fries is the thickness of a steak
fryer or a potato wedge is just
unforgivable a lot of bars are going
with like instead of nachos they're
calling they're making nachos out of
tater tots now that's what I said last
time tots yeah you make yeah you get
nachos with waffle fries or tots and
it's awesome
yes it's awesome these this actually is
a pretty good match up because the
waffle fry and the tot serve as a base
food yes for many other types of dishes
uh and the waffle is also an an upcharge
it's it's not an actual fry fry I agree
I mean people do have strong opposing
views to the top can you just scroll
back pimp for a second uh a little more
to the little
more little more to the uh the person
who was uh oh right there right there
right there verifi would rather stick my
head in the fryer than E A tater tot
somebody where's that coming from I
don't know I think that's harsh but some
some people attach them to breakfast and
and they can't get over some people
attach them to an abusive
father I was forced to eat my Tater TOS
or I wasn't allowed to watch television
this is a very good point that we didn't
make last time waffle fries are the
worst three fries in a large no thanks
that's a great point with waffle fries
you only get that's an amazing Point
yeah yeah now you could argue the
surface area is why you only get five of
them but there is something to you want
to pick it that kind of meal yeah well
here's the thing the the the big uh one
of the big selling points of the waffle
fries is how it can hold condiment in
its nooks and crannies obviously I'm not
telling anyone something that they don't
know waffle fries hold the cheese sauce
better tater tots are for toddlers now
we didn't touch on that but a lot of
people do think that a tot is a child's
type of it's geared toward children like
if there's a menu if there's a kid's
menu T and and like sometimes the fries
will be Ted
we're in bad shape if the waffle fries
go to the finals right now I know
because here's what I don't want I don't
want I don't want curly versus waffle
cuz did you do this on purpose the same
thing did you do this did you Rak this
no you I thought just like you I thought
like you and like Joe that Tater Tots
was going to be the thing to beat which
is weird because it is the only it is
the black sheep of the whole tournament
should have went against curly uh waffle
should have went against tradish then
tradition and Curley would have went to
the
finals because that's really what this
is about today well I I thought that I
don't know who's going to win between
traditional and curly the momentum
against tater tots now was building all
right let's see let's see who W turning
I do have one question what's the
difference between tater tots and hash
browns is there a huge difference well
uh uh uh uh uh uh mechanically no it's
the
same and you have been giving me some
good last last I just love when you dig
your heels in and say something
completely serious that sounds so absurd
I mean it's the same rest it's the same
makeup mechanically was a great choice
to but uh but yeah but but just this
it's the shape that's why like when when
I think it was I think it actually was
Chick-fil-A home of the waffle fry I
think chick-fil was the first place I
ever saw that that actually served tater
tots as their breakfast hash brown
instead of a hash brown wend it might
have been Wendy's is one of those Wendy
I've only e remember once in my life but
I got to tell you I didn't until I saw
it at the fast food place I was like oh
yeah it's the same thing as a hash
realized exactly can I ask you what
where the name tot came from what it
what why why tot is TT like already a a
word that references something in that
shape they mean kids maybe it is really
just for kids you know what too I'm
wrong
Burger King was the first Burger King's
side with their chis sandwich was the
little like hash brown discs that were
basically Tater
to oh what like kid another story okay
one famous account is that a Salesman
with a ukulele created the term to
promote oid's New Creation another story
is that a contest took place and a
housewife made the name using Tater for
potato and tot for baby
effectively naming the new food well
believe whichever one you want I always
took the Todd as like baby cuz it's like
a little but isn't that a toddler I
don't I've never called just like a I
called him a t a toddler I never said a
tot it's small I just thought it like it
was a kid thing is is there a proper
definition for the word TT sometimes if
it says like little child it'll be TT on
the crossw word puzzle if it's like
three letters oh really okay so maybe it
is TT a very young oh so so that's what
it is already okay I always look it as
like baby potatoes okay so it is a tot
all right let's see who won pimp Pimp's
going waffle fries oh no oh my god oh no
oh my god oh no wow wow waffle are going
to the finals wow waffles D I mean we
thought we thought wa waffle just lost
to tots okay that I mean that's I I
can't got news for 9,000 votes and
waffle fries wins 56.5 to 43.5 I thought
it I thought it didn't have a chance I
thought tots was going to clean the
floor I got news for you but I can't
tell you until after the next
battle
okay you think that it's going to be
waffle curly or it's going to be waffle
traditional and you're going to defend
waffles since they're the same as curly
since you keep insisting that that just
bit you in the ass that just bit you in
the ass but no shouldn't I pick if we
both feel like wait what why do you get
to tell me what I have to pick because
you have insisted repeatedly that waffle
and curly are the same thing and I keep
saying no they're not you keep saying
yes they are it's not about no it's not
no pip is backing me up it's not about
if waffle and C are the same it's about
the two finalists what I like more well
I know I like traditional the best of
any fry and I know traditional is going
to go the final and you didn't take
traditional you went against traditional
with the sweet potato fry watch your
mouth I'll take waffle fry and I'm
taking waffle fry to the promised land
let's see if curle goes to the final oh
then think will yeah then you're done
all right let's go your goose is cooked
curly versus traditional fry Joe S and I
know where we stand I'm traditional he's
curly where do you stand uh traditional
for sure of course it's only a lunatic
would say the curly I'll say I'll say
7030 traditional fries are in my life I
don't need to I don't need to think
about them curries have to be either
found or attained but F you know like I
don't I I I I I get hit with a curly fry
course in the street I mean I get hit
with a traditional fry peach ice cream
has to be found are attained it doesn't
beat it doesn't beat vanilla and chocol
I'm saying is I can get hit with a with
a traditional fry crossing the street a
curly fry is more special to me I get
that it's more special it's more unique
it's not better than a traditional fry
it's it's more fun to eat I listen Joe
here's my argument with the with the
curly fry and you back me or or disagree
my main argument against this fry is two
arguments number one it is rarely ever
cooked properly the middle is colder or
softer than the outer edges yes and
number two that seasoning and this is
really my my main argument that
seasoning which consists of garlic
powder onion powder salt pepper and
paprika we looked it up that seasoning
is so robust that it takes away as a
it's too much as a side when is a robust
seasoning a negative when is a robust
seasoning a negative you're eating a
burger with onion and tomato and pickle
and all these flavors and you go to the
fry and it's like godamn I got to be
honest if I'm dealing with food in
general I want it to be robust I like
the seasoning
sometimes but not all the time I think a
gripe against the curly fry is it's hard
just to dip into a regular dip because
it's not like long enough yep it's a
good point no I like it what do you mean
it's like a slinky you could hold it up
here it'll drop down two inches past
where you listen I got to be honest with
you and he's our guest so I want to be
nice but Joe saying it was too hard to
dip a curly fry and maybe question his
intelligence all you can be is honest
I'm glad you said
it might have happened to
it's like I'm right
here Joe what curly fry hurt
you no you know it's it's way more messy
to dip I I understand what you're saying
it's it's it's errant yes I will say
this too about the cor honestly you dip
it in a condiment the condiment adds
weight the slinky like quality of the
curly fry sometimes you're coming back
up it starts to elongate and it gets
like sloppy it starts to drip and stuff
you're say what you're describing is
what I find fun I I like my Slinky type
of cubert snake that extends it's like a
spring I like that and I like that I
like like having to do this like when
you have to go under it I don't like I
like it I think maybe my Crux in this
argument is I don't ketchup is even my
favorite thing to put on fries I like
barbecue sauce I like uh I like a nice
Thousand Island Special Sauce like I
like all kinds of stuff Joe I'm not
against ladies and gentlemen thank you
Joe I'm a big McDonald's guy as as we
all know I I I'll take the barbecue
sauce and the hot mustard any day of the
week at McDonald's dunk the fries in it
you're talking crazy though what you're
saying right now no I I like I like
ketchup too though but
Florentine Island you just said you
don't like dipping like that I wouldn't
be I wouldn't be fair if I didn't say I
wouldn't be if you guys if you're only
listening Joe has if you're only
listening Joe's wearing a face of
disgust that I've only seen the day the
morning that Princess Diana
died was funny though was like it's
funny cuz you do eat in McDonald's I
remember I took you to McDonald's
remember you bought like all this
and you're like do you want anything I'm
like no I'm good you're like really wait
when did you take me to McDonald's years
ago in La after we both had horrible
sets somewhere like I just got to go get
something to eat and you didn't eat
anything no I think I probably got an
orange drink where were you like driving
me home or something yeah gosh it's all
good though but you do you love
McDonald's I'm like oh my God you the
one time I remember being in the car
with you we were leaving the American
Legion after me and Burr's birthday we
went in and did that birthday
celebration uh and after same tripley
gig that we both were it was awful but I
remember we were in the car and somebody
gave bir that bottle of scotch and it
was like McKellen 25 or something M and
he and he gave he handed me in the back
seat of the car and he goes he was
driving and he goes D Roa get this stuff
away from me I can't have it in my life
I'm trying not to drink and I go well I
don't really like Scotch but this is
neat and then you said well I'll take it
and I was like no I'm going to keep it
and I still haven't opened it and I'm
just letting it acrw value oh that's
great I I would be being dishonest if I
didn't say that on like when I do get
McDonald's which is few and far between
usually on road trips for work um I do I
I love I mean ketchup is number one but
I I do tend to go and dip them right in
that sweet and sour sweet and sour the
McDonald's sweet and sour the McDonald's
barbecue but other barbecues no that's
the only barbecue I like to D dunk friiz
but I would say like 70% of the time I
just use ketchup I'm just saying every
now and then I little Thousand Island a
little barbecue sauce and that goes
thoroughly against even ketchup goes
against the flavoring on a curly fry
that's why I think the bigest gripe is
you just can't have regular ketchup on a
curly you think it's a clash of flavors
exactly well and that's that's what I'm
saying it's too damn come back around
Joe I'm back in your good graces yes and
Joe that's but that's what I was saying
last time the curly fry has too much
flavor on it that when you dip it in
stuff it doesn't taste right a flavor
town I never heard of a gripe it has too
much flavor it's you just heard one you
you you just said he said that the
flavor clashes with ketchup that's what
I'm saying because of all the seasoning
on it you can't even dip it in anything
but in of itself the flavor is is is
great if you add something I mean I
could take I could take a I could take a
wagu beef steak and tell you what not to
eat with it listen I I agree I agree
that if you had to sit with fries all by
themselves and weren't allowed to dip
them in anything and weren't eating them
as a side dish to anything then yeah the
the seasoning on Flavor FL curly fries
might take it to another level where it
feels more meal likee or or substantial
but what I'm saying is is a fry does not
serve that purpose almost ever for
anybody it's a side dish and the curly
fry takes away two things it clashes
with your the food you're the main
course and then you can't dip it which
is the most fun part of a goddamn fry
you can dip it I have two things to say
real quick first of all you also said
and I'll tell you something right now I
don't think I don't remember the last
time that I got a McDonald's fry that I
was satisfied with the with the
temperature of Cook
I mean they they send those things out
now they they all need another minute in
that fryer they send them out almost
like raw potato and you're telling me
that curly fries get soggy in the Middle
where everywhere you should I think you
said McDonald's fries sorry that's mean
every McDonald's no bab buddy buddy they
come back they come TR me this is one
time I can say without doubt I eat there
more than you do there's no golden brown
there's no crisp they come they come
medium medium at best if a little soggy
and they they're white they look like
really wrong on this they are they I'm
telling you I asked them for well done
and they they still come out and they
still like who's making requests at
McDonald's you get what they give you
and what they give you is perfect and
that's why you get it what they give you
is I you're lying to me no you're lying
to my face if you don't admit McDonald's
undercook their fries quite frequently
no no no no no no in fact the only
complaint I've ever heard about
McDonald's Fri is oh it sucked I got the
ones that were sitting out under the
heat lamp for too long I when they're
fresh they're the best when those things
come out of the fryer I've never had
them under they're always out of the
fryer banging they've got it down to a
science they chemically treat these
fraking things well whatever wherever
they landed on right now that they
solidified with this process right now
for me they're not of the fries of old
from McDonald's they are they are
basically they need another minute in
there who do you think eats at
McDonald's more uh definitely you sour
the guy that got sent a golden arches
signed by
McDonald's knows his name shout out
McDonald's we haven't shown the fans yet
but McDonald's sent this
aide yeah man take pictures and bring it
in yeah why don't people dip fries in um
mustard I do sometimes because the
Kish goes with the mustard do hot
mustard
iald freak me out for years what do mean
you know Florentine bit on ketchup but
what was his bit I mean oh I I'm not
going to do it justice but it makes you
rethink every time you eat ketchup
well what was the premise though it's
just all sugar yes yeah I Terri can't do
a Jim florentin imitation so I don't
want to do a horrible one but the way he
does it's amazing it's so great it's I
buy the hind no sugar added hin is the
only ketchup on Earth let's be honest I
don't even like if you have hunts I'll
leave your restaurant I hate I hate to
show I'm C now I'm doing my a joke but
like I don't I don't I don't want your
own take on ketchup right right like I
just went hind yeah yeah when you go
into hunts that that's saying something
a place to carries hunts that's saying
something Hunt is dark and look I'm sure
the hunt family is a swell family and
I'm sure that they have their dieh hard
people but for me where I came up it was
like Hines is like the catalac dark it's
dark I'm from Pittsburgh like it's hin
hun is the prgo of the Pepsi jar sauce
Ragu Ragu is hin you know what I mean
Ragu is the say if you had to buy jar
sauce they gave you prgo or Ragu no if
you had to you would go Ragu cuz it's
the one that tastes it's in there yeah
hunts taste too sweet like Prego all
right let's see who won this one curly
fries versus we got 8,000 votes about
and this is a big one here I want uh uh
anyone want to take swing swing at the
numbers I would be shocked if classic
did not take this I I think it's going
to be
under under a 6% margin of Victory but
I'm I'm hoping it's curly I'm actually
hoping it's I don't know I'm hoping it's
curly fry this way I get a horse in the
race him's taking traditional oh oh my
God yeah yeah yeah okay let okay first
of all this is this is huge upsets huge
upsets today you're thinking it's going
to be tater tots versus traditional I
mean that's all anyone said that's all
you heard all week in the Press everyone
said it's going to be tat tots verse
traditional and everyone said those are
two powerhouses they're kings of the
tradeit they cannot be overtaken and
both of them both of them were knocked
out in this tournament okay I feel like
Mal Kyper on draft day I think any of
them
right you Rigg this you rigged this I
mean guys if you're listening it's a
it's actually a clean no decimal point
it's 8,000 votes just about
52% curly fry to that against
traditional fry traditional fry is the
constant everything else is the variable
everything else is a satellite off of a
traditional fry it's just the way it is
you would think that that would go and
roll right through TT we thought but
honestly tater tot was a black sheep I'm
more shocked at this and I'll tell you
something it says something it speaks
volumes if the the original the real
deal original fry was beat by a
predecessor you should be fearing curly
fries right now my friend well I I'm I'm
pissed cuz I don't want waffle fries in
the final that wasn't one of my top
fries and I maintained from the
beginning that waffle fries shouldn't be
in the bracket of eight because I said
waffle fries are way too close to curly
fries and it just doesn't make sense to
to me because if curly fries weren't in
I would feel I would attach my love of
curly to Waffle yes but now you got
curly versus waffle in the finals you I
think you rigged this I think you see
that was just seasoning versus unseason
I think you knew you figured out the way
to do this where curly would go in
against Waffle how dare you the just I
just look at the feces just dropping out
of your mouth right now it feels like
you you you looked me and you in the
face and you told all of our listeners
tater tots is going to destroy
everything and traditional is going to
destroy everything and so why you we
didn't pay no mind of the matchups
before this now you have a gripe against
the matchups you told me that those were
the two that were going all the way what
does it matter who they faced wait do
you have to tweet something now yeah I
do yeah you should tweet that out okay
the finals here we
go folks uh I like to go to concerts I
like to go to concerts I like to go to
concerts I can't say it enough but I
don't like committing way in advance I
like buying my tickets last minute and
when you buy tickets last minute you
want to be able to know you're not
getting screwed that you're getting a a
good deal and uh you want to do it
stressfree that's why game time is such
a great app you shouldn't have to worry
when you're buying tickets for uh the
next big event no matter when it is
you're buying them game time gives you a
fast and easy way to buy those tickets
for all the sports and music and comedy
and Theater events near you whatever the
event is that you want to go to they got
tickets for it with killer last minute
deals all in prices views from your seat
so you can see what it's going to look
like where you're sitting and the best
price guarantee
game time takes the guesswork out of
buying tickets uh last minute tickets
Flash Deals Zone deals and again that
guarantee uh uh and then also event
cancellation protection job loss
protection all that stuff the guarantee
by the way is if you find tickets in the
same row uh as folks uh let's talk about
mint mobile you know signing your
LifeWay to a big wireless provider is
kind of like being trapped on a roller
coaster from hell uh I agree I uh am
very picky about who my wireless
providers are and the first thing I want
to know is am I getting my money's worth
well I got news for you folks mintmobile
is here to make sure that you're getting
more than your money's worth month after
month of insane bills and unexpected
Thrills with certain providers it really
stinks you know you don't need the
overages you don't need the surprise
fees it's just not fun okay but
mintmobile what are they offering you
they offering you wires PL Wireless
plans at $15 a month unlimited talk text
and data for just $15 a month they're
here to rescue you with premium Wireless
plans for again more than affordable
prices all the plans come with unlimited
talk and text highspeed Data unlimited
delivered on the nation's largest 5G
Network so ditch big Wireless with mint
Mobile's limited time deal and get
premium wireless service for just 15
bucks a month to get your new Unlimited
Wireless plan for just 15 bucks a month
and get the plan shipped to your door
for free go to mintmobile.com
tastebuds that's mintmobile.com tastbuds
cut that wireless bill to $15 a month at
mintmobile.com tastebuds you really
think he rigged it to Roosa what do you
think he did I absolutely think he
rigged it curly fry versus classic why
would he do that why would that why
wouldn't it be curly fry versus tater
tot and classic versus waffle that's
what it should have set you up he always
set I know I know God damn it does this
count now as three losses for me today I
believe so uh as per what you shouted at
my face like I was a dog a few minutes
ago
yes you yell at dogs to Rosa that's not
nice well
no God Almighty dude this sucks man this
sucks it's just the Battle of a spice
now though cuz they're basically the
same fries I will maintain that waffle
fries do not often have that seasoning
and that they are still better than
curly fries I still believe that I hate
curly fries I really don't like them but
that doesn't mean they're going to win
or lose I mean that that's it's people
love curly fries well let me say
something real quick okay yes let me say
something because
actually I think this is actually a
actually if you think about it this is
really anyone's game here because they
very similar right but they took out the
two beasts right so I mean I can't tell
right now where people are weighing
curly versus waffle at all waffle beat
tater tot tater tot was the biggest
margin of Victory we've ever seen so
that says a lot about the waffle but the
curly took out the traditional so the Ry
beat Duke I mean
ex um you know what I'm saying dude like
actually I mean we didn't think this but
it as per the the results these are
these are the two two two big guns so I
have to imagine this is going to be
extremely
close feel free to speak I have no idea
what's going to happen here I'm not
happy cut the tension with a with a know
I mean it's I'm my mind's kind of blown
on everything by the way I loved your
new special I oh thank you very much oh
congrats buddy thank you while while put
this while I'm putting this poll up why
you talk about it uh well we shot it in
Chicago all comedy presents uh it's it
has a 70s detective show theme in a
sense of the beginning and the end or
like a Quinn Martin production it's
actually it's so genius it's so genius
and then uh we were going to have little
things in the middle like you know act
part one part two and then have the
epilog but everyone thought the standup
was so good uh Pat myself on the back a
little bit that we just ran the hour and
then there's some sketches at the end oh
that's cool man or just some quick you
know quick little things because we set
up all the action parts for the
beginning so like well we're here all
this m money we're having on shoots
let's just write some stuff to do while
we're here mhm that's awesome man and it
a fun night two great shows and uh my
fans broke the liquor record at the
10 absolutely that's great man I mean I
I we were watching on a hey baby watch
the intro I thought it was absolutely
genius and you could see how funny and
and just endearing Joe is he's one of
our favorites uh you got to check got
check out I love all things comedy's
YouTube page you can check it out uh
that's awesome buddy thank you yeah yeah
that's awesome uh but all that you're
like you're like a like that's nice but
I mean I get waffle fries on my mind
you're like a curly fry to me okay I
don't see you that often and when I do
I'm thrilled and I just I I really I
just really love you I love you guys too
yeah you're like a curly FR of me I've
never cared for
you that's
great he's so strong that the pump like
hurts it like legitimately
hurts um dude that's awesome on the
special who are you going to take in the
fry battle I know you know what who I
would pick or who I'm going to take who
yeah which fry are you siding with curly
or waffle I almost feel like I got to go
curly because if I'm going to have a
waffle fry I might as well have the
curly seasoning to me it's like the same
thing M this was what I said before the
tournament even started Joe this is
you're anti- seasoning but waffle fries
don't have seasoning I don't know where
this thing is of wa I like that I like
attaching that to him Joe's anti-
seasoning I like it he's anti everything
else so why not anti seasoning they're
the same thing but in different shapes
they're they're not though you don't
like a bold robust
flavor I have had more waffle fries
without seasoning than waffle fries with
seasoning I've had normal fries with
seasoning they're called seasoned fries
I'm not going traditional fries are the
same as curly fries they have seasoning
no they don't sometimes they do
sometimes they don't here's the thing
we're talking Cuts not seasonings yeah
so the cut of the waffle fres is incred
me that's what it distinguishes it
otherwise we could say truffle fries oh
they're traditional with some truffle on
it but my point is is the my point is is
everybody is equating waffle fries to
seasoning that's not the what a WAFF
that's not what makes a waffle fry a
waffle so then the waffle people will
will speak well we'll see the average
person though is saying the seasoning
thing is my point but that's one of the
strengths inherent to the curly fry and
getting back to the point of how many
you get you get more with curly fries
yeah you get the more fry effect than
the waffle I'll tell you I also like
looking down at the little paper like
boat that they come in you know and I
like I like anticipating when I when I
take one end where where it's going and
if I took a long one or a short one and
when I pull up I play a little game with
myself like did I pull one of like the
like the the the really good ones
playing straws yeah yeah I'm playing
straws yeah yeah but I do I don't like
though how this become this little like
Chef little hey let's make the fries
presentation something just give me a
bunch on my plate it seem like they're
screwing me with like oh here's the
ketchup holder here's this here's like
five fries scattered to make it look
like a presentation i' rather just have
the guy a
hand
disgusting how do you make a curly fry
good good point like soaking it in
sewage water apparently yeah I'm sure
made different than a lot of than other
fries I mean that's so fun to me dude oh
look at that one that was like a full
long curl none of them are correct oh my
God it almost looks like a rotini pasta
I love it they're all
broken it's so fun it's a bunch of
random pieces and a couple curly cues no
by by the way just like with
architecture when you want to put a uh
when you want to make something round
it's always more difficult and more
expensive it's an art form to be able to
have curvature it is and and honestly
you know honestly the potato is is
basically in essence a bowl of clay and
and we're sculpting a curly fry we're
sculpting it you know do you seeall you
this guarantee you the curly fry is the
most difficult fry to make I bet you
that look at that look at the there
should be some Prestige that comes along
with that I'm sure the Machinery needed
to cut look at this they drench them in
this they drench them in this
you mean the delicious crispy coating oh
God it's so gross it looks like
worms looks like a bunch of worms and
then that happens too by the way I
forgot they all stick together and you
pick one up and 18 fries come up with it
that's kind of fun yeah I think you're
being a hater right now no no man waffle
fries all the way look at that I would
dive in that and roll
around I really would yeah you could you
could do fun stuff with a curly fry when
you're at the table with a friend you
could like put one right here and make
believe it's an earring and laugh about
it they look like they look insecty to
me they look you could you could you
could put a you ever put a pencil
through one that's fun and then it just
stays on the pencil like it's a holder
yes you could do it nobody's ever done
you could do it you could do it waffle
fries are just edible spoon for sauce if
you like sauce much just eat it by
itself this is going to make me so happy
I you know I realized the other day when
I was home uh just pontificating I
realize takes the W I'll lose all faith
in humanity thank you Shannon go ahead
go
ahead I did it to be a dick all all
right I was thinking the day about how
um I don't remember the last time that
we had a battle end and one of us was
like yes like we used to like be so like
like you know like like into the and I I
just feel like like ah like we we kind
of received the information now a little
bit more LAX than we did like I don't
know what it is but I feel like this is
one because of all the smack you talked
I I tell I'll tell you what it is I feel
like this is going to be a for either
one of us that wins I feel like it's
going to be one of those sweet Victor
you've beaten me You' I'm like a wife
I'm like a wife in a dead marriage I
don't have the I don't have the energy
to fight anymore whose fault was
it whose fault wasn't someone stop
working out caring caring about their
appearance making a nice dinner yeah
exactly exactly talking when the game
was
[Laughter]
on
what is it is it really let's read a few
of these Sophie's choice I I get it
waffle has more opportunity to get lost
in the sauce c c unorganized mess guys
there's something about wabby saabi
that's great whoever says waffle just
block me now you've been brainwashed
crazy people are tast taking are
trashing curly fries like what the f
happened to your taste buds you can read
some Joe curly fries really they're
soggy pieces of of never cooked
right always have other things thrown in
with them regular fries onion rings
zucchini curly fries can suck a big fet
no what what no nothing nothing I'm just
trying to make p job oh oh sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry it's simple F wle fries
they should have never made it this far
curly boys for the win I mean you
speaking my
language uh let's keep going because I
this is much more I thought this was
easy it says it was difficult um waffle
fries are what people with class and
distinguished eat curly fries or what
Sally
eat wow that's a direct shot huh okay
I've always seen curly fries at Arby's
and nursing homes I don't even I don't
why the curly fry the curly fries is the
most impractical invention since the
double decker couch that sounds good I
never heard you read some what's a
double decker cou I don't know you know
a double decker couches no curly fries
used to be the like upgrade they hey
we're a little fancy and then they came
out with the sweet potato fry yeah and
that that you served it and that that's
the thing now that's yeah that's the up
well that took a that took a fat turd I
also would like to point out the the the
the esteem of the curly fry because
there are instruments as we just saw in
binging with babish in his video there
are instruments sold in culinary stores
to cut curly fries I have never seen an
instrument sold to cut a curly fry you
mean or waffle fry excuse me there are
instruments sold to cut waffle fries
I've never now maybe I'm wrong but I've
never seen because they all come from
Cisco and they frozen Cisco they're not
fresh I mean that's why you've never
seen one no one makes a homemade also I
think you need a patented machine to
make a curly fry either that or you you
have to be a sculptor and that says
something I sculptor or or or have a
factory in North
Dakota Joe can disrespect the curly fry
all once but it's the champion of fries
Arby's over McDonald's come on man
you're nuts uh I see a lot of people
attaching themselves to Arby's in this
debate waffle fries are worse than
911 waffle fries all day because nothing
wor sorry because there's nothing worse
than getting three good fries and a
bunch of inedible potato Pebbles I agree
seasoned curly boys are just salted
waffle fries are often times undercooked
cuz they're so big curly fries are never
undercooked that's not true they they
they they are I I I got to be honest be
honest I've not had undercooked waffle
fries I've had undercooked curly fries
yeah I I mean I'm sure I've had some
that that get soggy but I could attach
that to any any fry so if I'm being
honest uh pimp are we there it's time
yeah we're there all right so we got uh
here it is this is a big one hold on
before you hit it pimp where where you
where you going with this before you hit
it um I guess waffle okay and guys you
want to give me uh some some some
only 2200 votes but that's cuz we put up
yeah yeah put it up a minute ago it's
okay that's enough to get the L test I
think it's going to be closer than I
thought it was going to be I there's a
fighting chance for waffle fry after
reading the comments but who knows we've
been misled before the the the the the
performance of the original fry in the
first round made me scared cuz I thought
Curley was always going to the finals if
I could have chose two it would have
been curly tots so for the fact that
waffle is even here in the ation at the
Big Show I can't believe wful fries beat
tots I know that's that says something
too so it's really for me it's anybody's
fry game free throws I do have an
anxiety right now that I haven't had in
a long time on this show what you say I
said toss didn't make their free throws
Joe you're a bet man where you going
here I'm a bet man I'm a 0 for two I'm a
hawk in my watch uh Joe I
think I I don't know I I I I I think
Curly's going to win by by by a pubic
hair all right plug your special one
more time because we're going to end as
soon as we do the okay I say uh uh uh
bartnik a killing in Chicago it's on all
things comedies YouTube page or Joe
bartnik dcom the link is right there
great okay here we go here we go pimps
choos and waffle
fries
oh
wow
wow yes yes yes my instincts were
correct curly one oh my God Joe curly
Fri takes the win
53.8% to 46.2 let me tell you something
right now I would love to see what the
results are at the close of this poll in
24 hours I mean I think that's enough
margin to not be able to overcome we've
seen it flip-flop when it was closer but
that is a good battle man I I this is
also one battle and I'm not just saying
this cuz I lost it's because of the
close margin it's also because of the
tight window since we posted it I do
think that that is a battle that one win
not your other two today that one win I
think is worthy of a revisit how about
this how about this he's pulling Hillary
Clinton
yeah yeah he's not accepting the fee but
I mean that's that's so close it's been
up for 15 minutes no let me see your
emails uh no um uh all right no no you
know what I think that's fair actually
and I will that's what I just said how
about this next time we get on we'll
look at the results at the end of the
24-hour poll give it the full run that
no one's ever gotten cuz it's a big
tournament it deserves it that will be
the final yeah now we taking only one
loss from this tournament no we're
taking all the wins and losses right so
those have to be tallied up today you
ate you ate a sandwich yeah so we
scrubbed we probably scrubbed even on
this okay basically you might have got
one win over me but uh but uh
anyway I still love you babe I love you
too taste buzs they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools going
to fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they coming to the